in the company of uh mayor bill de
blasio and the first lady shalane mccray
and their son is there as well
according to the mayor's office they
were all wearing face masks they've
removed them for the photographs this is
apparently the first time that the duke
and duchess have visited new york made a
public trip there since moving to
california and the one world observatory
is the building that
has taken the place of the rebuilt world
trade center complex it is the one world
trade center and now the tallest
building in the us
they're visiting uh this today and then
tomorrow they're going to make an
appearance at global citizens live which
is on central park this is to talk about
achieving global vaccine equality
they are apparently going to call for
the g7 and eu to donate at least a
billion covert 19 vaccine doses
immediately for those for those most at
need
the last time that prince harry was in
new york we think 2013 uh that was not
long after hurricane sandy uh devastated
the area uh the last time meghan markle
was there uh that was for her baby
shower in february 2019.
we believe
apparently they haven't brought their
children two-year-old archie or
three-month-old little bit with them
for this trip